generation die hier bleibt im elsass
findet man noch die schützen geräten aus
dem ersten weltkrieg hier bekämpften
sich franzosen und deutsche erbittert
hier drehte regisseur vadim jendreyko
für sein neues filmprojekt
[Musik]
also der arbeitstitel für den film heißt
suche nach europa also ich hab einmal
anfangen mit mitglieds traf um zu
erfahren was die und europa verstehen
mit geologie den historiker krieg mit
tamino mit spezialisten sara nuru mittag
macht dann festgestellt dass es viele
gibt die rede immer für europa als ich
das lange antwort ich eine eigene
fischer tropfen da sieht man in europa
xxi
das hätten wir als witz gemeint sind
letztlich das wort europa inflation mit
verschiedenste bedürftige auf klare
worte und ich habe gemerkt dass es
vorderhand negative bedeutung ist dass
es mit krise die finanzkrise eurokrise
flüchtlingskrise und somit oder und habe
merkt der veraltet ist
europa hat man ganz andere vladyka das
wort hat andrej vladyka
[Musik]
der mord an dem metro sind die stadt
belegen dass kiefer menschen unbedingt
in den hügeln
da hat man viele koptische hügel und
südlich die punkte eigentlich verwandte
wo käse front wo in erster weltkrieg 30
menschen gestorben sind immer furchtbar
höllische stellungskampf will das ist
geschwächt die genau das hat wir boten
wurde kontrolliert dass es luft linie 30
km vor der schweiz von basel
[Musik]
das ist horror sie so sind glüht
kniehoch in kadaver in urin kot
gestanden und hand genannt kampf euro
[Musik]
und wenn ich die leute drauf wo der
torwart frage der antwort hielt vor dort
hier pflanzen wachsen dass man die
strukturen aussieht dann begann das
plötzlich kurz mit dem kriegs romantik
das ist frieden in sarajewo statt
der film wenige jahrzehnte grausame
schreckliche krieg eigentlich mit in
europa stattgefunden was konkret durch
die zum beispiel ag gründet von
franziska möglichkeit gilt können andere
dax-konzerne singen
die familie hätte opfers beklagen
familie wollen dann aber klappte und die
lizenz an dass der riss es ist nicht gut
gefahren über europa er klar um gottes
willen das sich über hand gleich bar
also sehr persönlich und sehr subtil
[Musik]
mitsche ziel ich barcelona